for this week's mini election trip I'm
off to Oxford West and Abingdon to visit
the Conservative MP Nicola Blackwood and
find out how her campaign to hold one of
the most marginal seat in the country is
good how do you say your campaigns going
so far are you in full-on electioneering
mode or is this just your day to day
your day to day canvassing well we've
been in full-on election mode for quite
some time and but we've been canvassing
three times a week and twice on
Saturdays for many months now this is
not just so that we can have the right
information for Election Day so and it's
also so that I can get right information
in order to be able to do my job as an
MP I think you saw that today what we're
doing a survey canvassing we're not only
asking people about their views about
voting but we're also asking people
about their views about the things which
I should be working on and how I can
better represent them so is a
combination of the two really and what
kind of messages have you been hearing
on the doorstep from people well we're
hearing people who say that they are
strongly back and conservatives you have
one lady and they want to hear strong
messages coming out and lift generating
messages well they want to hear the
Prime Minister speaking out and being
clear that the Conservatives are doing a
good job in government which I was very
happy to endorse and we're also hearing
people who are talking about units some
of the infrastructure ones we have
locally they want a strong community
champion in their MP and that's what I'm
trying to do for that this is one of the
most marginal conservative seats in the
country with no point three percent I
believe is your majority there's a good
chance the Lib Dem vote is not going to
be as strong and does that make you feel
confident in the Wales it's still a
battle when you go on doorsteps with Lib
Dem voters well having a majority of 176
does not make you confident it makes you
feel like you have to fight for every
vote and I feel like as an MP that's a
good attitude to have anyway I don't
think that we should have a an ounce of
complacency um clearly we you know we
look at the polling and it gives us you
know some confidence that we're doing
some good things here and that people
know what we're doing um but when it
comes down to it we're going to fight
for every last vote because
is a lot can happen between now and Paul
day and we can't take anything wrong
since you've entered Parliament there's
one of the 2010 as the big intake of 12
of young Conservative MPs and you've
certainly been less vocal and in the
national media then some of your other
your other compadres it was that a
decision because you're such a marginal
seat and was it something it just
happened naturally well I sort of made a
conscious decision that I wanted to
focus very much on fighting for my
constituency I wanted to get to the 8th
of May and know that I had done
absolutely everything I could to fight
for this seat that I wouldn't have any
regrets that I hadn't focused enough on
it I learnt a very big lesson when my
opponent at the last election turned
down a that was everlasting it was
turned out there very important hustings
to go and do an interview in London and
sent his agent instead I can tell you
that for 300 businesses in the room that
went down like a lead balloon I never
wanted to be that MP so I focused very
hard on being a good constituency MP and
doing my work in Parliament to the best
of my ability and we'll have to see what
kind of response occurs that's it for
our first stop of the mini election to
join me next week to find out how the
general election is being fought in a
different part of the country